the United Nations is calling for a
humanitarian pause to the fighting with
Isis in Raqqa Syria
so civilians can evacuate us back forces
began an offensive against the group
self-declared capital back in June UN
estimates 20,000 people are trapped and
at risk Isis released a new propaganda
video that claims to show a 10 year old
American boy u.s. officials now tell CBS
News that clues in this video simply
seem to indicate that this little boy is
an American but the details of how he
ended up with Isis are still not clear
the boy makes threats against the US
that appeared to be scripted our ongoing
series called issues that matter
explores the pressing challenges our
country faces and today we're taking a
closer look at our nation's fight
against Isis the State Department says
Isis has lost about 78% of its territory
in Iraq and 58 percent in Syria since
its peak in 2014 nearly one third of
those losses have happened in the past
six months Brett McGurk is the special
presidential envoy for the global
coalition to counter ISIL
he served now under three
administrations and just returned from a
12 day trip to the Middle East
Brett good to have you here welcome so
much for having me so I know you were
just in Iraq tell us what you learned
well there's an Iraq and Syria had the
honour of traveling with Sectary Madison
to Jordan and also Iraq but about a week
ago I was just north of Raqqa where
where we heard about this report look I
think we have to keep things in
perspective about seven months ago in
Raqqa Isis was sitting in a major city
using infrastructure of a city to plan a
huge attacks against the United States
and our partners that was happening only
six or seven months ago right now
they're fighting for their life block by
block about 60% of the city has now been
cleared it is extremely extremely
difficult and we're mindful of this
report about potential humanitarian
casualties and let me say two things we
talked to a number of the IDPs have come
out of Raqqa about 300,000 now and
displaced people people who fled the
fighting all these people in Raqqa who
are fleeing Isis they're fleeing into
the lines of the force that we're
working with and we are now working with
with the United Nations to try to take
care of them about 20,000 people remain
left in Raqqa what they tell us is that
the number one thing we have to do to
how
these people is to feed Isis Isis is
using civilians as human shields they're
using a Children's Hospital in Raqqa as
their primary a base of operations so
the number one thing we have to do is
defeat them and defeat them as soon as
we can and it's going it's going well so
given the gains over the last six months
while president Trump has been in office
how was the strategy changed since
President Obama well a couple that you
know when President Trump came and he
said look he charged the entire national
security team focused like a laser on
destroying Isis so that meant let's look
at what is working and try to reinforce
those efforts and let's look at things
that haven't worked and try to improve
them one thing he did very early on was
delegated authorities down to the lowest
level in the field what that means in
practice is that as our military experts
see an opportunity they can seize it so
the reason we're 60% through Raqqa now
is because we saw an opportunity about
four or five months ago at a town of top
guy I was just in this town here about a
week ago it's over a body of water it
took an off a major audacious military
maneuver to do that we saw the
opportunity delegated authorities to the
field helped us take advantage of that
an operation launched within a week and
we're able to catch Isis by surprise
which really helps set the conditions
for getting into Raqqa so you delegate
authorities down you shorten the
decision-making cycle it makes a
difference in the field we also are
making sure that our coalition is really
participating in this effort so I saw
with my own eyes just north of Mosul I
think it's important for your viewers to
understand what these brave Americans
are doing in the field I was in a town
called telltale spoof where a Navy SEAL
gave his life about a year ago fighting
Isis helping the Kurdish pesh MERGA
fight Isis in that town today about 80%
of the population is returned the
restoring their community and we are
helping with the coalition to try to
make sure that demine landmines are
cleared water can get back and running
electricity is back and I saw with my
own eyes as these families come back to
these towns that only six or seven
months ago were controlled by Isis so I
think it's what you're saying what
you're saying bread sounds very
encouraging and then we see that video
that they're claiming is excuse me
claiming as an American boy little boy
and they're describing him as an Isis
Cub such a cute name for such an ugly
philosophy when you see something like
that do you believe it what do you make
of it
well let me say look the leader of Isis
is a guy named backer backer of egg
daddy he claims to be the Caliph of this
territory in Iraq and Syria he's losing
all of his territory he we haven't heard
from him since December and instead
they're putting out videos of children I
cannot obviously I can't confirm this
video or who this child is they use
children as human shields they try to
recruit children as suicide bombers they
have used children inside Iraq to blow
up children's soccer games to attack
ice-cream parlors of families going to
get celebrate the Eid that's what this
organization is and that's why the
sooner can be defeated the better so we
are moving as fast as we possibly can
mindful of how difficult it is the
latest attack against the West wasn't
staged from Iraq or Syria it was from a
village in Spain so the global game of
whack-a-mole with these guys how is that
affected by the efforts on the
battlefield so bill it's a great
question because our focus in Iraq and
Syria they're no self-proclaimed
Caliphate where they used to sit and
plan and plot all these attacks that's
where they play in Brussels that's where
they planned Paris that's where they
were planning against us we have to
shrink their territory at the same time
through a global coalition we build a
global coalition of 69 countries and
working to share information as we
collect that off the battlefield of who
these people are
we're putting them into a global
database gives you information that you
can figure out where the Celtic key to
stopping these attacks is information
sharing
so the overall effort will shift a
little bit from the military phase in
Iraq and Syria to law enforcement
intelligence and sharing information one
of the newest members of our coalition
is actually Interpol because we're
building a global database we've 19
thousand names now of known terrorists
either joined Isis or tried to join Isis
trying to move into Iraq and Syria
and we want to make sure that every
law-enforcement agency every border
patrol officer can check it out a base
and stop these people in a routine
traffic stop as of trying to cross
borders this is a long-term effort the
long-term fight and information-sharing
trying to close a net globally to make
sure these people can't travel and we're
just as focused on that as we are on the
military side of Iraq would you say
long-term I think everybody wants to
know how long is long but when Nora said
you're just back from Iraq literally
just back you just got back last night
just got back
I did I got back last night you know it
was interesting even in Iraq I was in
Saudi Arabia before going to Iraq and
some interesting things going on in that
part of the world Iraq and Saudi Arabia
have really not had any diplomatic
relations since 1990
I visited the Iraq Saudi border crossing
was just open for the first time in 27
years there's a rapprochement going on
between those two countries which will
be very helpful in terms of the post
Isis phase making sure that these guys
can never come back and then we have
some stability there I'm thinking you
need to come back to the table at a time
so much to talk very interesting thank
you thank you great thanks to you